[Music]
david is in new mexico hi david how are
you
hey dave hey george thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
so uh my wife and i we've really been
committing to going through the baby
steps
and right now we are
doing baby step four
and um
great but i want to know
what i wanted to know was was when you
guys thought would be a good time
or a good baby step to start thinking
about a baby um
so we're at that point where we're
considering it
um i don't really like uh public schools
in our area so i want to send them to
private school
do you guys have any suggestions as far
as when to start thinking about that
yesterday or
you should already have babies go get
babies babies are awesome
what's holding you back right now
well so the main thing is to both my
wife my work uh she's a labor and
delivery nurse which probably explains
why she's really wanting the baby
um so uh my concern is once she has our
our first baby that i would really like
for her to be able to stay home
uh that's gonna have a shift in our
income yep and so i don't want us to
have to take any steps backwards since
we've been able to move
forward so well you shouldn't have to
take steps backwards you structure your
household to where you live on your
income
can you afford to live on your income
alone david today
um
so so the biggest issue would be the
mortgage um
you know we we took on the the mortgage
prior to the whole you know dave ramsey
baby steps um you know so it's a little
bit more than our uh that portion of our
income
um so right now at my current income
that probably
might be feasible but we would
definitely have to do the whole beans
and rice rice and beans again
um
you know so well it may be that you you
choose to not live in that house to have
babies
or you choose to not live in that house
to have babies in her be at home with
them or she works um you know three
twelfths
which a lot of ours which a lot of
nurses do and a newborn's not going to
private school so we don't need to worry
about that right now either
at least not in my house no
do they have private schools for
newborns that's correct yeah oh boy yeah
the uh um they got everything for
newborns but yeah
listen we don't tell people when to have
children
uh it's not a financial step the baby
steps have nothing to do with babies
and so um you know you have babies when
you and god decide to have babies and
that's that's the time to have babies
and i'm a big fan of babies yeah and it
becomes a line item in your budget
that's it yeah it's an attitude you know
and so what you're doing uh
david is your you're saying okay
i really want my cake and eat it too i
want to live in this house i want to go
to private schools i want her to not
have to work
and i want us to uh
you know to to
prosper and go forward and you can't
have all that you're gonna have to
choose something your income's gonna
have to go up
she's gonna have to maintain some kind
of income
or you're gonna live in a different
house
or or or
and thus is the joy of raising a family
but um yeah i i highly recommend it
anyway yesterday
it's uh it's the babies are the best
thing i've ever done and i've done some
really cool things but babies are the
best the only thing better than the
babies of course is the grand babies
and um if i don't know how great
grandbabies were i'd have been nicer to
their parents so there you go rachel and
daniel and denise they ended up just
fine they they turned out they're gonna
turn it off it's it's okay but yeah it's
because of their mom